konnichiwa hello I'm Shinya Takahashi
from Nintendo earlier this month we held
a Pokemon direct for the latest games in
the series I booked him on sword
okay then pokemon shield the developers
from Game Freak showcased the new
gallery the location of your new
adventure yeah and some new Pokemon
you'll encounter there it will be a
while until these games launch so please
stay tuned by the way in these games you
can use certain functions of the
pokeball plus accessory allowing you to
take a Pokemon from one of these games
out for a stroll through the real world
with you you may not be able to use the
device as a game controller but if you
spend some quality time with a favorite
Pokemon of yours then something good
might happen in the Nintendo booth at
this year's e3 fans can play pokemon
sword and pokemon shield for the first
time anywhere in the world in this
gameplay demo you can challenge one of
the gems in the gallery region with the
one and only water gem where the water
type Gym Leader Nessa will be there
waiting for you if you're attending this
year's show I encourage you to
experience
between Dynomax Pokemon it reaches an
advanced strategy from this region
also immediately after this Nintendo
Direct stay tuned for a live gameplay of
pokemon sword pokemon shield on the
Nintendo treehouse live and now I'd like
to shift gears please have a look at
this
[Music]